You're an entrepreneur.
You just started a business and you're asking
that question everybody struggles with.
Who do I hire first as my first employee?
Do I hire somebody in sales, marketing, operations,
accounting, finance, product development,
legal.
Who do I hire first?
Now, before I answer that question for you,
it's a very simple answer.
But before I answer that question for you,
you got to keep one thing in mind.
If you're a startup, and you're an entrepreneur,
and you're already funded, you have money,
that group that gave you the money, is already
expecting you to have a team together, because
they're not going to give you the money without
you having a team to show here's who I have,
okay?
I'm assuming that I'm talking to the group
that doesn't have money today.
You're without money.
You're trying to stretch every dollar.
You're wearing multiple hats yourself.
Like, you're the CEO, CFO, COO, CMO, you're
every single thing in the company, you're
doing right now.
It just so happens your business card says
CEO.
So who do you hire first?
Look, you got a lot of departments.
And a lot of people will tell you who to hire
first.
For me, it's a very simple thing to be processing
and thinking about.
So look at it this way.
Any sports team that already has a position,
if a team already has a quarterback, you're
going to go get another quarterback?
No.
If a team already has a very, very strong
center, you going to get another center?
No.
If you're running a business, whatever your
strength is, the first person you hire is
your opposing strength.
That's your first hire.
Your opposing strength.
Well, Pat, what do you mean opposing strength?
If you're in sales, most salespeople who are
very, very good in sales, are not necessarily
very good in operations.
Now if you're very good at operations, you're
probably not very good in sales.
If you're incredible at product development,
most product development people don't like
to be around a lot of people , so you need
sales.
If you're in sales, and you're a great salesperson
like Ray Kroc, but you don't know what product
to develop, you need somebody here [product
development].
If you're someone who's very good with money,
and maybe even you have money, but you don't
have an idea, maybe you meet up there [with
product development].
But the point I'm making to you here is whatever
your opposing strength is, that's what you
need to start off with.
Now, let's say this other thing for you to
be thinking about.
I'll go dig a little bit deeper.
In the game of sports, everybody that builds
a team, they generally build it around their
philosophy of what's the most important thing
to invest their money into.
Let me explain what I mean by this.
Some teams build around one player.
Okay, so for instance, Chicago Bulls, Michael
Jordan, they built around one player.
Michael Jordan was the main player.
Then they brought supporting cast to be around
him.
The San Antonio Spurs builds around a system.
They're not building around one personality,
one player.
That's why they've been playing for 20 years,
and they're winning 20 years.
Whether they go from David Robinson to Duncan
to Lamar, Marcus, Aldridge, and Leonard, it's
a system they're building it on.
Right?
I don't know what you're going to be building
your business and your philosophy and system
on.
But what I could tell you is whoever you choose
as your first next, determines what you value
the most.
Sometimes, sometimes generally the most logical
people, the people that are most.
. . and everything is very logical and organized,
like the administrative folks, sometimes they
think they need this [finance and accounting].
Sometimes they think they need product development
only.
Logical.
Sometimes they just go, everything is just
way too logical, and they forget that you
need sales.
If you don't have somebody selling, you don't
have volume revenues coming in.
If there's no sales going on, done.
It's just purely a done deal.
Right?
So back in the day when a lot of companies
would do very, very well and they would develop
these guys that would become the CEOs of the
company, everybody who got started with the
company back in the '60s and '70s, you read
about, they all had to do sales at one point
of their career.
Why?
Because they had to touch the customer to
know what the customer's like.
That is my focus.
I like to hire this [sales] first.
So if you're not sales, I like to hire this
first.
When I got started, I'll tell you for myself,
I was this [sales] first, and I'm marketing.
This [sales and marketing] is me.
So guess what I needed?
I needed here [admin], I partnered up with
here [product development], somebody that
designed the products that I needed.
So without this, I don't have a product to
sell, so I got product to sell.
And I needed admin.
Then I got this [finance and accounting].
I already had somebody that was helping me
out with this [finance], but then I got this
and upgraded this to a whole different level.
So as you're thinking about this with your
business, whatever business you're running.
Take a sheet of paper out and ask yourself,
what is my strength?
And what are the opposing strengths that I
need?
Go recruit that person.
Go hire that person.
Stop hiring people that are just like yourself.
It's cool to be around people that are just
like yourself.
It's fun when you're around people like yourself.
That's good maybe when you have a friendship,
but not when you're running a business.
You're trying to create a business and a business,
if you run out of this [money], you shut down
the business, you're going back to having
a job.
So you've got to make sure you make the decision
of who you hire first in a very, very proper
way or else you won't be in business for too
long.
Hey thanks for watching this video.
Let me make a case for why I believe you need
to subscribe to Valuetainment and also join
the notification squad.
Look, there's two ways you can learn about
business.
One of the ways is to go to college.
Learn a bunch of theories by professors who
have probably never ran a business before.
Or you can watch Valuetainment, ran by entrepreneurs
who have built and sold businesses.
You can learn from our mistakes and what we
did right.
And by the way, I'm willing to bet anybody
who goes and takes this boring route vs. watches
Valuetainment, I'm putting my money on this
person that watches Valuetainment's going
to beat the person that goes to college.
You don't believe me?
Test me on this!
This is why I'm so certain you need to subscribe
to Valuetainment and learn the content so
you can also be a successful entrepreneur.